les amis qui qui qui qui qui meurent qui
sont déchirés par de bal c'est terrible
vous racontez des scènes de carnage et
absolument apocalyptique
hein Lucien bajoko bonsoironsir
bienvenue parmi nous merci alors vous
êtes étudiant à l'université de de droit
de de
Kinshasa Congo ex zaï mais à 12 ans vous
avez été enrôlé dans les milices de
Laurent désirer Kabila le tombeur du
maréchal Mobutu et vous êtes devenu ce
qu'on appelle un cadogo c'est-à-dire un
enfant soldat pour vous la mitraillette
c'était pas du tout un jouet c'était une
arme qui qui pouvait tuer c'est cette
enfance africaine que vous racontez dans
un livre coécrit avec Cassia Clarence
publié chez plomb qui s'appelle j'éta
enfant soldat alors tout commence en
1996 vous allez avoir 12 ans vous êtes
un enfant plutôt heureux issu d'une
famille aisée il faisait quoi vos
parents Lucien mon père était homme
d'affaires alors un jour d'octobre vers
midi vous sortez de l'école et là vous
décidez de ne pas attendre le le
chauffeur qui vient vous chercher
régulièrement et de de marcher et sur le
chemin vous croisez un ami qui s'appelle
Pascal Pascal lui est militaire dans
dans l'armée de de mobutou mais il est
contre Mobutu il est partisan de de
Kabila et il vous convainc de rejoindre
avec lui les rebelles de Kabila et vous
le suivez oui sans discuter sans
discuter parce que je je je voudrais
bien un jour aussi manier les armes
j'avais ce sentiment là de manier les
armes un jour ouais et de libérer mon
pays euh dictature de Mutou qui av 30
ans et il faisait il se faisait aussi
qu'il y avait la haine qui était en
moi suite à certaines histoires au
pillage des militir de mobutou ils ont
eu à me fouetter un jour c'est militaire
donc il y avait l'acheminement de choses
qui avait pu fait que je puisse être
décidé que je puisse me décider vite
pour aller voil libérer mon pays de la
dictature alors Lucien vous partez avec
Pascal vous imaginez pas une seconde que
votre existence va va basculer vous êtes
excité vous êtes joyeux vous voyez déjà
en schwarzeger en chck Norris en
Jean-Claude Van Dam quoi vous avez envie
de jouer avec les armes oui en fait
quand on est enfant je savais pas que la
vie d'une personne était sacrée je
savais pas aussi le sens de la mort
ouais et c'est c'est donc je je prenais
la guerre comme un jeu d'enfant ouis
comme un jeu vidéo oui donc on jouait
parce que c'était l'ambiance qui était
c'est par après que j'ai pu comprendre
que la guerre la vie d'une personne est
sacrée et que on peut pas mettre même sa
vie en danger comme ça pour une
politique ça se pull voilà alors vous
partez vous partez directement sans
prévenir votre famille jusqu'à un centre
de formation au Rwanda et là à peine
arrivé vous êtes dépouillé de vos
affaires on vous vole votre veste que
votre mère vous avait rapporté d'un d'un
voyage et vous êtes battu immédiatement
avec des
branches oui en fait comme il nous
disait il fallait ôter l'esprit civil
ouais ils nous ont blayis pas possible
c'est horrible difficile a expliqué C
étant donné qu'on était des enfants on
nait pas AFF faire c'était du plus fort
est toujours la meilleure on s la de
laffire et mais on est obligé de
supporter cela ouais alors on vous
demande de dormir par terre il y a même
pas de de palme vous dormez à même à
même la terre même le sol hein au sol
pas de maison dans des tentes petites
tentees ouais et puis beaucoup de de
sports des pompe on vous fait courir
enfin on vous dit tu dois apprendre à
avoir le cœur dur c'est qu'on essaie
de vous endurcir au maximum vous un
enfant de de 12 ans quoi il faisait tout
pour que nous soyons violents que nous
ne puissions pas comprendre les faire de
vous des bêtes sauvages oui voilà alors
certains meurent de coup de botte dans
la tête dans le ventre enfin surtout
ceux qui veulent s'enfir du centre de
formation parce que on ne s'enfit pas du
centre une fois que vous êtes là vous
êtes obligé d'y rester en quelque sorte
vous donner prisonnier des gens chez qui
vous vous êtes engagés si vous essayez
de fuir et vous attra on vous tue ouais
on vous tue on vous tabasse pas possible
avec des branches de de ou alors il y a
aussi l'endoctrinement c'estd qu' on
vous bourle on vous bourle le crâne on
vous dit du mal de Moboutou alors ce qui
fait qu'à un moment déjà vous le déteste
au départ mais à force de vous
endoctriner vous finissez par avoir
qu'une seule envie dans dans la tête
comme ça c'est vous dites liquider ces
chiens de mobouthiste liquider c'est yen
mouist c'est-àdire vous êtes
complètement fanatisé oui euh souvent le
soir vers 18h 19h quand on nous donit la
morale on essa un peu de nous expliquer
de nous faire voir comment mobutou
est dictateur comment il a traité nos
parents comment il nous a traité comment
il a mis le pays dans la goufre et tout
comment mou tu es plus mauvais et cette
idéologie là qui nous changeait l'esprit
de plus en plus ça ça ça nous incitait
de de de le faire partir vite qu'on
avait toujours envie de le faire partir
vite avant qu'on termine même le la
formation bah oui oui vous voulez
toujours aller combattre à partir de là
vous vous interdisez de de penser à
votre famille parce que vous dites c'est
c'est terrible c'est comme un poison qui
s'instile en vous donc vous vous vous
refusez même de penser à votre passé à
votre famille à votre mère à votre père
en fait ma mère je l'aimis beaucoup je
l'aimais beaucoup et ma sœur j'avais une
sœur Yvette que j'aimais tant mais il se
faisait qu'à chaque fois que je pensais
à eux je pleurais je pleurais tous le
jour tout le jour et je souffrais fort
je n'arrivais plus plus à me tenir je
n'arrivais plus à surmonter cela mais
après un temps je j'ai trouvé que
c'était comme un poison parce que suite
à cela je n'arrivais pas à faire autre
chose j'étais toujours distrait à
certains moment je me suis dit comme je
trouve comme si c'est un poison qui qui
qui qui qui pourrait peut-être mettre
fin peut-être à à ma vie un jour il
fallait que je mette fin à cela et le
jours que je pensais à cela je me suis
conscientiser je me suis décidé de ne
plus penser à cela voilà alors bientôt
vous êtes nommé instructeur et là à la
de 12 ans vous découvrez l'alcool les
cigarettes ça participe aussi de
l'endoctrinement ça cette idée que le
tabac commence à vous plaire vous dites
au bout d'un moment mon meilleur ami
c'est le tabac vous vous commencez à
avoir des vis quoi oui on donit on donn
les tabac un peu de tabac et euh du
tbaco à l'état brut qu'on nous
distribuait et dans la nourriture c'est
par raè que nous avons compris que qu'
qu'on nous mettait un peu du chanre mais
on nous interdisait de de de prendre du
chanvre au centre de formation mais il y
a un ami euh que qui m'avait dit un jour
qui était cuisinier casse qui qui qui
m'avait dit un jour non voilà vous savez
pourquoi vous avez des courages souvent
c'est parce qu'on vous metetttez à en
fait un peu du chanvre de la nouriture
et j'ai vite compris effectivement il y
avait certaines ambiances qui étaient en
normal à certains moments après avoir
mangé quoi oui en plus vous étiez drogué
donc alors finalement vous êtes pas
désigné pour aller au front vous restez
au centre de de formation Lucien là vous
devenez commandant ce qui est terrible
c'est que vous couvrez l'exercice du
pouvoir euh vous commencez à tabasser
les les jeunes recrues à votre tour
c'est-à-dire vous faites aux autres ce
qu'on vous a fait quand vous êtes arrivé
en fait c'était une sorte de revongche
de se faire voir de de de goûter au
pouvoir vous savez parce que quand nous
sommes arrivés on a vu comment les
autres cétaient des enfants fait des
hommes comme nous et qui qui nous
traitaent comme des animaux et nous
sommes dit voilà on m'a fait souffrir
donc je dois faire souffrir tout le
reste qui vient et on on voudrait
maintenant mettre en exercice petit
pouvoir là qu'on avait sur les autres
c'est comme ça qu'on a pu faire souffrir
les autres qui sont venus vous tabassez
les autres vous tabassez les jeunes
recrus et vous profitez des filles aussi
c'est comme ça que vous perdez votre
virginité c'estàdire qu'en fait il
suffit de dire à une fille ce soir tu
viens chez moi préparer et la fille est
obligée de venir quoi oui on avait ses
pouvoirs là on était leurs instructeurs
ils avaient rien à nous dire vous étiez
leur en fait comme l'armée les ordres se
discutent pas ça s'exécute donc ils
avaient pas de choix je vous dis pass
chez moi vous devez passer chez moi si
vous passez pas chez moi il y a des P
qui qui vous attendez là voilà ensuite
vous allez au front vous êtes capitaine
de 16 personnes à l'âge de 13 ans et là
vous êtes envoûté par la musique de
votre arme c'est vous avez l'impression
des jeux vidéo là vous pouvez tirer vous
pouvez tuer des gens vous vous rendez
pas compte de ce que vous faites en fait
au début là on se rendait pas compte on
s' rendait pas compte on était in cité
par l'ambiance vous savez il y avait des
chansons qu'on chantait de de la
révolution de la gare il y avait
l'ambiance des chansons qui nous fait
faisait voir que nous sommes en train de
libérer notre pays qui qui qui de la
dictature des chansons qui qui qui nous
faisaient voir que même si nous perdons
notre vie c'est c'est c'est c'est nous
perdons la vie pour notre nation pour
notre pays même s'il y a trois quatre
qui meurent les deux qui restent vont
construire le pays et et on était vite
incité par ces sentiments là et quand on
tuait on ne voyait pas qu'on tuait des
gens on trouvait que c'est l'ambiance
parce qu'on chantait quand on tu on
chantait on ne voyait pas que c'est la
vie des gens qu'on était en train de
perdre c'est ça quand vous croisez un
corps vous dites ton temps est terminé
mon frère et puis un jour vous tuez pour
la première fois alors évidemment au
début ça vous fait un choc terrible vous
dit je me sentais étrange j'avais
l'impression que mes cheveux voulaient
sortir de ma tête et puis tuer devient
de plus en plus facile parce que les
enfants n'ont aucune conscience de la
mort et quand on a 12 ans on se rend pas
bien compte de ce qu'on fait Lucien
c'est sûr oui euh la première fois des
tué vous savez c'est c'était
horrible c'était terrible d'expliquer
cela parce
que vous savez quand vous êtes enf de
l'ennemi euh vous étz obligé de le tirer
parce que il y a certains principes de
la guerre quand vous voyez l'autre le
premier il faut le tuer parce que vite
on va vous tuer et je m'avais senti
vraiment euh emporté par certains
sentiments il y avait le char des pou
qui m'est sorti sur le corps
et en fait au fur et à mesure maintenant
de le faire et de voir comment les
autres tomes le en fait on les saute les
amis qui qui qui qui qui meurent qui
sont de Ch pas de bal c'est terrible
vous racontez des scènes de carnage
absolument apocalyptique hein au fur et
à mesure qu'on a eu l'habitude de tuer
de se battre sans sans sans scrupule
sans sans regret
ouais il y a des scènes terribles avec
un un militaire qui fait tourner un
enfant en tenant par une jambe et
l'enfant va s'écraser contre un mur
enfin c'est d'une c'est d'une sauvagerie
absolument terrible alors quand vous
arrivez à Kinshasa vous êtes accueilli
en en libérateur évidemment tout le
monde vous voit arriver avec Kabila mais
en fait les gens se rendent pas compte
que ces enfants sont devenus des
bourreaux et au bout de quelques jours
les les quinois les habitants de
Kinshasa commencent à avoir peur des des
enfants parce que les enfants sont
devenus des des monstres vous moindre
blague on vous tue moindre blague on
vous tue moindre blag on vous ture et la
population commenc à avoir Mar et tout
le monde il se disait mais ce sont des
enfants sont des enfants sont des
enfants et par après on en fait on est
vite taahi par par la population bien
sûr alors alors vous vous avez torturé
vous-même vous avez torturé vous
racontez il y a un jour vous vous
souviendrez toujours de ça c'est quand
vous enfoncez la la bayonnette dans le
dans le genou d'un mec et et vous sentez
une résistance et vous voyez le regard
du type et ça vous pouvez pas l'oublier
ça oui et a un type en fait il y a un
rbelle comme on peut appeler un rebel un
ennemi qu'on avait capturé un jour comme
d'habitude ça s fait quand vous êtes
capturé par la main
et si si tu ne te tues pas tu ne te
suicides pas et si vous êtes capturé
vous serez vraiment maltraité et ce
jour-là c'était horrible c'était ma
première fois de participer aux tortures
direct et euh c'était horrible de de de
les faire et souvent des fois si je
pense à cela et euh ça fait du mal au
cœur et ça me fait en fait ça ne me met
pas à l'aise ça ne me met pas en paix
c'est c'est c'est l'armée n'est pas la
place pour les enfants ouais l'armée n'a
pas la place pour les enfants c'est
c'est c'est bien de démobiliser parce
que vous savez aujourd'hui euh la
majorité de la jeunesse africaine se
sont lancé dans des en fait au service
de mag les armes vous comprenez je me
suis dit aujourd'hui que demain
après-demain que serait l'Afrique ou
l'humanité dans le sens que la majorité
de jeunes qui est qui qui qui sont
l'avenir de demain sans lendemain se
lance dans ce genre d'histoire et queils
ne sont pas instruits demain
après-demain on aura quel genre de
médecin quel genre de dirigeant ou quel
genre de militaire qui parce que nous
étions de guerriers nous n'étions pas de
militaires parce que pour pour pour être
militaire un officier g général il faut
passer par les académies militaires et
comment ils seront assumer certains
responsabilité du pays de l'Afrique du
continent d'Afrique ou du monde avec
cette instruction qui n'a pas
atteint l'objectif de de de ou le
principe général alors vous vous en êtes
sorti vous faites des étude à
l'université de droit de de Kinshasa
mais vous croisez encore dans les rues
des anciens enfants soldats qui sont ça
qui air quoi il vous dites il se nivent
du kérosè ils savent pas quoi faire ils
sont ils sont perdus oui euh je les
croise toujours parce que nous avons
l'association nous avons fait
l'association euh avec des amis qui qui
aident les amis qui aident les amis à
comprendre cela à se
maintenir malgré la souffrance à se
retenir à prendre la la bonne position
dans le sens que nous sommes des enfants
nous pouvons pas continuer à travailler
pour l'armée nous sommes en train d'être
euh exploiter et que nous devons
préparer notre avenir pour que la
démobilisation réussisse il faudrait
restaurer la paix parce que tant qu' il
n'y aura pas la paix tant qu'il y aura
la guerre aura les enfants soldats on
démobilise aujourd'hui demain et
après-demain nos jeunes frères aussi
vont suivre vont chercher à défendre
leur chacun peut-être cherchera à
défendre sa famille son ami ou ou
lui-même pour se sentir en sécurité et
il va se faire enroller pour prendre les
armes pour mieux se sentir en sécurité
quoi alors Lucien aujourd'hui vous avez
trouvé votre réconfort dans dans quoi
dans la religion
oui euh dans la religion aussi la
religion m'a beaucoup a je suis
catholique et euh en fait je dirais
quand je suis passé au centre des de des
transit les les psychologue selon moi
n'ont pas pu effacer tout ce qui était
en moi mais avec le concours de de
l'église d'un encadreur euh de notre
encadreur à l'église en fait à la
chorale par parce que je me suis engagé
la chorale
magnificate avec son encadrement parce
que l'encadr là fut mon professeur au
secondaire il savait bien que j'étais
militaire il m'a vraiment encadré avec
son apport l'apport de Dieu la prière et
j'ai pu retrouver ma
paix on ne sait pas quoi dire hein mais
on n' pas des des mots pour qualifier
ces personnes qui ont obligé des enfants
et qui obligent toujours aujourd'hui à
des enfants aller à la guerre il n'y a
pas des mots et et la deuxième chose que
je pense qui a a créé les armes qui a
vendu les armes pour qu'il s'entretu le
frèr africains et on a mal au cœur de
voir se déchirur dans un seul pays comme
les comme les Congo hein et j'ai dit que
il y a un temps qu'il faut pas il faut
pas perdre le temps que quand vous
arrivez trop tard et bien il y a
beaucoup de des dégâts qui sera très
difficile de de de de de faire
ressusciter ces personneslà mais ce
jeune il a il a eu le courage de de
lutter contre lui-même ouis et tout ce
qu'il a vécu mais c'est l'horreur et
pourtant et bien il dit il a trouvé la
paix mais grâce à Dieu et et on le
souhaite et on le on appuiera toujours
et et on souhaite que tous les autres
enfants qui sont encore dans la guerre
puissent suivre son exemple oui parce
qu'il y a pas que il y a pas
qu'osï en Côte d'Ivoire il y a beaucoup
de d'enfants soldats moi ce qui m'a
frappé c'est quand il dit estce que ça
me rappelle quand il dit j'ai été
instructeur on m'a battu on me torturait
et puis quand je suis devenu instructeur
j'ai fait ce qu'on m'a fait un jour
j'avais quand j'étais en Algérie dans
les années 62 63 j'avais rencontré un
Algérien qui avait été fait prisonnier
qui avait été torturé et et d'autres
avec lui ét torturé et il me racontait
que un des types qui était torturé on le
ramené à la prison pentelant terrible
avec des PL partout et cetera et ce qui
le réconfortait c'est de raconter les
tortures qu'il fer subir plus tard quand
le pays serait libre à ceux qui l'avait
torturé ou ça m'a toujours frappé
ça comme quoi il faut faire d'effort
pour humaniser notre notre terre
l'humaniser parce que on se croyait à
l'année 2000 quand on passait
à une époque qu'on va être tous des
frères et bien malheureusement nous nous
entrons dans un autre re où où n'existe
pas cette fraternité où où on s'éloigne
les uns des autres hein et quand c'est
enfants soldats mais ça il faut lutter
avec toutes nos forces pour que ça ça
cesse et et tous les gouvernements ce
qui est de les pays qui ont des enfants
soldats devrai à quand ils aent imposer
que ou interdire et de ne jamais aider
un pays qui a des enfants soldats et
puis ça c'est l'Afrique mais ne disons
pas c'est l'Afrique c'est l'Afrique ça
s'est passé en youoslavie c'est-à-dire
en Europe c'est-à-dire à quelques
centaines de kilomètres de nous ouais il
y a eu des enfants
soldats vraiment c'est
terrible la majorité des amis en fait
quand nous sommes venus pour la
libération duizï la majorité de des en
de de de de libérateurs soitdisant entre
guillemets étaient des enfants de 12 13
14 de moins de 18 ans aujourd'hui que ce
sont les enfants qui sont les
combattants du siècle or nous ne devons
pas faire cela les adultes ne veuulvent
pas se taire à cela nous devons chercher
à
humaniser la terre nous devons chercher
à préparer l'avenir de ces enfants de la
jeunesse de demain parce que vous vous
savez demain après-demain cette
génération va passer et c'est nous les
jeunes qui vont prendre relève et
qu'est-ce que nous allons faire si nous
n'avons pas conscientisé le vieux pour
nous préparer
aujourd'hui parce que vous vous avez
déjà réussi votre génération et nous
maintenant le jeunes donc nous devons
nous unir nous le jeunes entre nous de
conscientiser le jeune et n nos frères
jeunes aussi de se conscientiser pour
préparer l'avenir l'humanité de demain
l'Afrique de demain ou le monde de
demain FL non mais c'est vrai que là tu
rentres dans des témoignages où un
moment tu sais nous on est habitué à des
émissions de variété dites de
divertissement et là c'était pas hyper
divertissant son histoire donc il y a un
moment tu fais waouh qu'est-ce que je
suis en train d'entendre qu'est-ce que
je ressens comme vibration donc après me
demander ce que je peux dire là-dessus
qu'est-ce que tu veux que je dise si
j'ai quelque chose à dire là-dessus
c'est qu'il a un moment j'ai pas compris
merci Lucien et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de inardit tube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce
bleu